Hello there!
Welcome to our show.
Of course, I'm Conan.
We're coming to you once
again from the Largo Theater
here in Hollywood in Los Angeles.
And I'm very excited,
because for the first time
since the COVID outbreak
I'm joined in person
by my pal Andy Richter!
Andy's with us. Hey Andy!
[Andy] I'm over here!
Where?
No, back here! Hi!
Okay if I take my mask off, right?
Yes, I think we're not
only six feet apart,
I think we're about 36 feet apart.
Right, as you requested.
I requested that long before COVID.
Yes, and people can't tell,
but there's a wall of
plexiglass in front of me
that we've really spent, like three hours,
lighting it so you can't see it.
Yeah, we broke into seven
different Applebee's
and stole the plexiglass from
their salad bar to construct-
Your dream of a perpetual sneeze guard
around your life is coming true.
How are you?
This is the first time you
and I have been together.
Yeah!
You're looking well.
Thank you. Yeah, I'm
pretty good, you know?
I've been packin' on the pounds,
just, you know, for the
nuclear winter that's coming.
You know, other than that...
Hair's gettin' long.
Yep. Yep.
Wow, look at you.
Lettin' my freak flag fly.
You too, I see.
Yeah, my hair's gotten long.
You're gettin' shaggy.
If I let it go it collapses.
If I comb it up into a pompadour
wave it becomes a tsunami.
Yes.
It becomes a crazy tsunami.
Some people have said recently online
that they're frightened,
(Andy laughs)
so I don't know what to do.
But I like it. I kinda
like just letting it go.
[Andy] Yeah.
This is a time to explore
different hairstyles,
possibly different sexual, uh...
What?
I don't know. You just stopped.
You said sexual and then you
just came to a screeching halt.
I know. I think I got
too real for a second.
(Andy chuckles)
And this is the point where we cut out
five minutes of you just crying.
(Conan bawls)
Quietly sitting there crying.
Ah, I've never been fulfilled!
I finally know who I am!
(laughing) The laughter doesn't help!
Now, here's my question.
You don't have to be
that far away from me.
Why are you that far away?
Just to be safe, you know?
I mean-
No! That's not being safe.
I know that you've been talking
to people mostly on Zoom,
but you get a lotta riffraff on this show.
So who knows? Like, what do you got?
Lithgow?
Yeah.
That guy's probably
just soaked with COVID.
(Conan laughs)
Yeah, Lithgow's kind
of a sketchy character.
Yeah. Yeah, he sure is.
This is what I like. You
36 feet away from me.
That's right!
In Row L.
L for likin' it.
Or loser.
Okay, that's our show.
We'll see you tomorrow.
I'm now gonna walk towards Andy.
Andy, you have to keep the
same distance away from me!
[Andy] Oh boy. All right.
[Conan] Here I come!
[Andy] You're a lot faster
than me though. Go slow.
(cheery music)
(Andy laughs)
It's my show now!